hello hiya hi what's your name my name's
sebastian
sebastian and where are you from i'm
from newcastle newcastle okay
do you live there or here uh i live in
newcastle yeah okay
off you go with the story sebastian well
many moons ago
um i actually went to school in
newcastle
um and there was a disco coming up
uh that was a really popular girl at
school um
the usual side of scenario all the you
know all the guys after
um i sort of waited to the last moment
last couple of days
um and asked the girl one of this
popular girl question
if she'd like to go with me she said yes
this was literally
i think the day before the disco um lo
and behold
the turns out that she was actually
gonna go with somebody else
um and that other person was actually
charlie
sebastian olympia that's the real man
how could this have happened to two
people
[Applause]
rachel gould but they're
very same yes you know who it is wow
you know at the time
and did you end up marrying rachel gould
um no not yet no okay
there's still time you know you don't
happen to have a sword with you do you
you could you could have revenge if you
want to do you want to
there you
i wonder when go tweet